[Music]
[Applause]
The Eyes of Texas used to be a popular
folk tune but today the song could be
about other eyes the eyes of a spy
machine
we live in the United States of
surveillance with cameras like these
increasingly positioned on street
corners and with much more invisible
spying online and on the phone anyone
who's paying attention knows that
privacy could be out the window that's
what former newspaper editor bill kavich
says I think the idea of privacy is gone
I think you have to you you have to
adjust to the fact that somebody
somewhere may be watching what you're
doing and it may not be the government
it may be General Motors it may be
General Telephone and Telegraph it may
be the drugstore on the corner all of
this is not happening by accident
well-funded powerful agencies and
companies are engaged in the business of
keeping tabs on what we do what we say
and what we
think Mass surveillance is the focus of
of this new six-part investigative
documentary series examining who is
watching whom and
[Music]
why some Americans are up in arms
including an internet entrepreneur who
says government spying could be a first
step towards a police state Alfredo
Lopez let me put it this way there is in
the United States all the technology
from drones to computers to surveillance
to day-to-day camera surveillance all
over the country there is a structure
and apparatus for a police state the
United States is not a police state that
is clear we are not that uh that I there
I draw the line but we can be and we can
be with a flip of a switch and the real
problem is I'm not sure that the people
of this country have become have uh not
become sufficiently unconscious of of
their rights and of the Constitution and
the purpose of the Constitution to
really put a Hal to that when it starts
and so you know that's the real battle
others believe spying is now a big
industry more about money allocated out
of fear than stopping terrorism Sam
antar is a convicted felon who says
there is a corporate angle it's a bigger
story than the NSA story is really
corporate surveillance of critics or
corporate surveillance of Rivals within
their own corporations in other words
Executives surveilling rival Executives
these companies are looking for the
Edward snowdens in their own world yes
to many in the world today
the face of America has a big nose for
sniffing and sifting mountains of data
phone calls emails and texts and with
many mouths silenced by paranoia to keep
what they decide is secret secret even
Hightech sector executives are deeply
troubled I'm incredibly disappointed
truthfully I had become uh disappointed
over the last couple years I strongly
had suspected this like many others that
this was happening um um but what I had
not realized is that actually now we've
created a situation where all Commerce
is unsafe all Communications are unsafe
you know the most things that we had
expected to be actually have some level
of protection completely eviscerated
just like Toys are Us is one of our
biggest stores for kids Secrets s us has
become an American Obsession and now an
explosive and divisive issue that
affects people all over the world is
important that the US is embarrassed by
this because there isn't a way around it
they should stop it they should stop and
deceased they should sign a treaty
saying they will not conduct cyber War
they should sign a treaty saying they
will respect the human rights of the
whole world taken together America has
become a surveillance industrial state
where everyone's business has become its
business and where one huge us
intelligence agency has been given the
sanction and unlimited amounts of money
to spy on the whole world and this this
series you'll meet a former undercover
FBI agent who says government spying is
out of control we want the intelligence
agencies and the law enforcement
agencies to have power to go after
people who are doing harm but these
programs are being done regardless of
any suspicion of wrongdoing and a
computer whiz who did the same kind of
specialized secret work that
whistleblower Edward Snowden did but for
the military well I mean when you work
for the government you're like here hey
I'm here to do a job you know and at the
end of the day go home and make sure the
job's got done right and it's really
that simple um and the federal
government has a lot of really
outstanding people that work for it and
I mean high and high level they they
wake up dedicated to make sure that it's
done to the highest level you can
imagine but sometimes you just have
people that just do their thing you know
they they become upset with what they
see you will also hear from Edward
snowden's personal lawyer who says that
his leaks to the public were leaks of
conscience you know Edward Snowden has
no desire to to harm his country in any
way um he believes that he's still on
the side uh of his former colleagues but
they just don't see that we've tilted
too far uh in the direction of
collecting information on innocent
people at the same time writer Andy
Greenberg of Wired Magazine says
snowden's Revelations are leading to
reform it seems that he's their worst
nightmare kind of Genius employee gone
Rogue what I do see that's kind of
remarkable is that his leaks are already
starting to inspire reforms even as the
government's uh the Department of
Justice calls for his imprisonment the
president himself is talking about how
the NSA needs to be reformed based on
what he's
released going forward I'm directing the
Director of National Intelligence in
consultation with the attorney general
to annually review for the purposes of
declassification any future opinions of
the court with Broad privacy
implications and to report to me and to
Congress on these
efforts stopping Mass surveillance is
also an issue that is building in
intensity I cannot stand this
anymore I can't as a mother as a
daughter I cannot try to explain this
situation to my children effort that's
uniting strange bed fellows from across
the political Spectrum I'm proud to
sound here with Democrats with
Republicans with progressives with
Libertarians because this is not this is
not about right and left this is about
right and wrong in this series we'll
tell you what NSA really does how it
works with Telecom and internet
companies and the threat it poses to a
free press and Democratic Values it's
not only a violation of freedom of the
press it's a violation of the Public's
right to
know information
is the oxygen of a democracy it's not
just about participating in Democratic
processes it's about being
informed that's what makes democracy
meaningful and when we don't have that
information when a very powerful entity
the government has the information and
the people don't that is not a very
healthy sign we will also show you how
whistleblowers hackers and activists are
fighting back and
support worldwide there's been a kind of
cat and mouse game between the
surveiller and the surveillance that's
been you know going on for decades uh
and what Wikileaks I think was the first
to show is that the MIT can have some
small or even large victories despite
their lack of resources now you know we
see that the the cats have cracked down
again and that the surveillance state
has responded but then Snowden you know
appeared as another win for the mice so
you know uh
I think that this is going to continue
these sort of um you know kind of tit
fortat but it does seem that the the
these Revelations by the mice these
moments when we learn when when
transparency wins out over secrecy
essentially are getting bigger over time
even as protests Mount the United States
government still supports a vast cyber
spying program what I've been very clear
about is is that there has to be a
narrow purpose to it not a broad-based
purpose but it's rather based on a
specific concern around terrorism or
counter proliferation or uh human
trafficking or something that uh I think
all of us would say has to be uh
pursued President Obama has called for
some minor reforms but critics are not
satisfied there's some things that I
actually like about Barack Obama uh but
I you know I'm clear about the fact that
politically he is my opponent he's my
enemy and he is clear about the fact
that you have to put into place a series
of controls that will uh uh preserve the
social order that's the only purpose for
this stuff many in the media have been
challenging the power of the
surveillance State too relying on leaks
because they can't always get access to
insiders who are afraid to to speak the
NSA has invited some journalists in like
for this Pro NSA CBS 60 Minutes report
the agency gave 60 Minutes unprecedented
access to NSA headquarters where we were
able to speak to employees who have
never spoken publicly before full
disclosure I once worked in the office
of the Director of National Intelligence
where I saw firsthand how secretly the
NSA operates senior correspondent John M
Miller later left the network to join
the New York Police Department as an
intelligence official Miller asked some
softball questions ostensibly trying to
understand what the NSA does and doesn't
do abely there's no you don't hear the
calls you don't hear the call you don't
see the names you don't see the names
you just see this number called that
number the this number the two from
number the duration of the call in the
date time group that's all you get and
all we can do is tell the FBI that
number is talking to somebody who is
very bad you ought to go look at it
later a widely read website showcased
another interview by HBO comedian John
Oliver asking what does it say about the
US press that the toughest interview
Keith Alexander has is from a comedian
it's been said that your motto was
collect everything is that true for
specific problems right but you do
understand that collect everything is
also the motto of a hoarder that's the
fundamental principle which ends up with
someone living alongside 1500 copies of
newspapers from the 1950s and six
mummified cats former officials like
General Alexander were off limits to our
series as vany Vines of the NSA made
clear rejecting our request for a tour
thank you for writing given the volume
of such media requests we can assist you
at this time with your
project the NSA had been created in
secret and designed to be invisible
although it's hard to hide more than
30,000 employees with a vast number of
buildings their tightly guarded
headquarters here in Maryland covers
more than
325 Acres they have a small army to
protect it from enemies foreign and
domestic as well as their own fire
department and SWAT
team yet these days you don't have to
get get on the inside for a stage tour
of the NSA to know what's happening and
that's thanks to the Whistleblower
they're all paranoid about one man
former contractor Edward Snowden alone
is suspected of making off with millions
of documents that we have only seen a
fraction of he's been called an Insider
threat I'm just another guy who sits
there dayto day in the office watches
what happening what's happening and goes
this is something that's not our place
to decide the public needs to decide
whether these programs and policies are
right or wrong in a recent appearance
for Ted an organization that features
diverse speakers Snowden said he would
do it all again despite his notoriety
and the charges against him and I want
to make it very clear that I did not do
this to be safe I did this to do what
was right and I'm not going to stop my
work in the public interest just a
benefit NSA deputy director Rick leged
later condemned Snowden at another Ted
Talk I do not like the way that he did
it I think there were a number of other
ways that that he could have done that
that would have um not endangered uh our
people and our our uh the people of
other nations uh through losing
visibility into what uh what our
adversaries are doing uh but but I do
think it's an important conversation
snowden's secret files have sparked a
global controversy and debate about the
role of American surveillance that seems
to have the world as its Target it has
fueled debates in almost every country
they're damaging here in the United
States because people obviously know
what the government is doing but the
Damage Done internationally is
spectacular not only did they get a lot
of governments really upset with
them that they can de I mean that they
can patch over but masses of people
throughout the world know that that the
United States government is surveilling
them and this is a major major uh
problem for them much of the focus of
public anger is directed at this vast
agency known by its three initials NSA
the National Security Agency also called
a shadow Factory or an enigma wrapped in
a riddle the author of this book
journalist James Bamford has even made a
documentary about the NSA for a public
TV science
for those in the know the joke was
always that NSA stood for No Such Agency
for those on the inside the joke was
that NSA stood for never say
anything banford and a small army of
critics are now dueling with former NSA
officials and their Defenders lawyer
Robert lit works for the Director of
National Intelligence and downplays the
dangers of the NSA um the intelligence
Community um and the executive branch is
subject to uh significant accountability
um we have accountability to the
Congress um people may question whether
that accountability is good enough
whether it's structured properly but we
still have a degree of accountability
and the president of course is
ultimately accountable to uh the public
the NSA is trying to convince the public
that it's not dangerous but at the same
time it's become obsessed with dangers
within a so-called Insider compromise
that is now consuming their
attention in the post Snowden period the
US government is facing a big problem
internally to deal what they call
Insider threats as many as 4,000 people
they suspect of perhaps getting involved
in leaking documents or being an Insider
threat on the other hand they have a
problem from Congress and the media
which is denouncing the NSA and
denouncing surveillance so they've come
up with a new term and a new program
it's called it's in this report here
National Security through
responsible information sharing now what
does that mean it's not really clear but
the idea is to coordinate the
intelligence community and to have the
people in Washington linked up to the
people at the local level even at the
tribal level on Indian reservations to
try to create a integrated uh police
state apparatus at least it could be
used for that although right now it's
just for responsible information sharing
and one of the things about this book
that I found interesting was the
acronyms the nicknames of all the
organizations that are part of this
network six pages of acronyms of
organizations in the responsible
information sharing
environment to explore the mentality of
analysts and Tech Wizards who do the
same work that Snowden did did we met
Brad suol a darket programmer and former
military intelligence contractor that
you were in a way doing what Ed Snowden
was doing at one point can you tell us
about that basically the exact same job
I mean depending on what government
building you're in I mean it's still the
same thing it's the same rack of servers
you still have the sipper net there you
have the regular Garrison internet if
you went out into the field you have the
Tactical internet tactical internets or
networks so when Snowden was monitoring
information of of various kinds uh he he
had I guess clearances did you have
clearances as well yep and he was on the
supernet so in doing all of that stuff
were you very conscious of the material
that you were dealing with being of a
high security nature mhm oh yeah you
have all the sensitive databases right
there even as intelligence agencies try
to keep their staffs in line reporters
have become another enemy and maybe a
bigger threat with many hard-hitting
reports win major media prizes and
pitting leaders of the mainstream press
against the lack of transparency by the
NSA he said warding the Pulitzer to
Snowden enablers is a disgrace anything
You' like to say back to him about that
you know I mean I look at Peter King's
condemnation as as an enormous badge of
honor why shouldn't you Mr Greenwell be
charged with a crime the Scandal that
arose in Washington before our stories
began was about the fact that the Obama
Administration is trying to criminalize
inv instigative journalism by going
through the the emails and phone records
of AP reporters accusing a Fox News
journalist of the theory that you just
embraced being a co-conspirator with
felony in felonies for working with
sources if you want to embrace that
theory it means that every investigative
journalist in the United States who
works with their sources who receives
classified information is a criminal and
it's precisely those theories and
precisely that climate that has become
so menacing in the United States is why
the New Yorkers Jane mayor said
investigative reporting has come to a
standstill what do you say to those
journalists that have been uh also
highly critical of this kind of
reporting on the Eris Revelations people
like David Gregory that are asking if
Glenn gral should be prosecuted it's
outrageous I don't know how he can call
himself a journalist and and talk like
that I mean look this is the job I mean
the the job is we're supposed to report
the truth if whistleblowers come forward
we're supposed to take the risk along
with those with those whistleblowers and
in society long ago decided that we're
supposed to have protections when we do
this this is what journalism is a
shining a light on what the most
powerful people in the country are doing
to them in the dark so we're going to
continue to do that no matter what David
Gregory and his friends say this series
will take you to a highlevel media
Summit held inside the New York Times
that debated the role of leaks and the
need to defend the Press well I think
there is a need for push back this
conference is a step in that direction
and there are
reporters uh and even even mainstream uh
news organizations that are pushing back
uh so there's an important fight going
on here the NSA could not have access to
as high a volume of emails and
Communications without the full
cooperation of telecom companies and
internet providers this relationship has
blossomed into a surveillance industrial
complex with a flow of personnel back
and forth between the NSA and its
contractors as the internet
expanded corpor ations I think saw the
possibility of making huge profits and
really jumped into it very very
aggressively but the important thing to
to to note is that the real heavyduty
corporate involvement in the internet is
only about six or seven years old that's
when they really swept in events like
911 enabled the NSA to grow into a 60
billion doll Enterprise with 70% or 42
billion going to contractor some led by
former NSA Executives in October 2001
the NSA had only given 55 contracts to
144 contractors by October 2003 that
number had grown to
7,197 contracts for
4,388 companies Snowden had been an NSA
employee who left to work for a company
called Booze Allen Hamilton Running part
by a former NSA director private
companies like these were given access
to the nsa's Top
Secrets this also led to an expansion of
spying even as Government studies found
that the FBI and CIA screwed up by not
applying the intelligence they had but
couldn't process to stopping 911 under
pressure from President Bush and vice
president Cheney the agencies decided
that traditional legal restraints no
longer mattered so immediately after
9/11 it was it was somewhat shocking to
me that there was um a general feeling
that was being expressed that the rules
didn't matter anymore that that uh the
FBI had been Unleashed and we were now
allowed to investigate who we want and
not worry about the legal restraints and
it concerned me greatly because I knew
from the history of the FBI that that
would lead the FBI into a dangerous area
that was going to impact the civil
liberties of innocent people and not
improve Security in fact even harm
security and I think that's essentially
what's happened keep in mind the Patriot
Act is what allowed them to grow they
were so you know kind of insignificant
they did so few little things but then
all of a sudden they became the number
one with a big fat check in addition to
their huge budgets technological
Supremacy and backing from Key
politicians who are supposed to exercise
oversight NSA had always counted on
support from a fearful public that's
changing says Attorney Ben Weisner of
the ACLU I think they're so used to
getting their way they're so used to
being able to invoke the threat of
terrorism and having everybody roll over
uh that they're surprised by this
environment uh where where those kinds
of dangerous threats uh are are not
scaring the public into submission But
ultimately this is about what do and not
what they say um and I don't think that
there is a great defense no nothing new
for me because back in the 1980s was
common knowledge that the NSA was using
many of the same tools that it's alleged
or it's come out to been using today why
do you think that is why are they doing
what they're doing it's it's not an
ideological issue because you have
democratic presidents you have
Republican presidents you have the far
left the far right they all agree on one
thing we all want to know what everybody
body else is doing so spying is is in
our Gan pool yeah spying is in the
American Jean Pool
unfortunately coming up
next we're here at the International Spy
Museum in Washington DC there are more
spies here in DC than anywhere else in
the world so it's appropriate that we
have this institution that really tells
the complete story of Espionage
internationally when you travel to
America's capital Washington DC if you
can afford the admission you can visit
this International Spy Museum to relive
the glories of the Cold War complete
with an exhibit on James Bond's evil
adversaries what you won't find is any
reference to the current surveillance
spying Scandal the key aspects of
Espionage that deception that uh art of
hiding information and disclosing
information really has remained the same
and this is the capital of it Washington
DC absolutely Washington DC is certainly
the capital capital of ESP and the
capital of deception in many ways yes
absolutely outside of Washington in the
Maryland suburbs is the capital of that
Capital merge on De K9 road then your
destination will be on the left the
National Security
Agency this super secret spy agency is
not hospitable to tourists or most
reporters who want to know what's
happening now we found that out when we
were told we were not welcome at this
heavily guarded Federal facility it has
more than 30,000 employees 32 miles of
Roads across 325 Acres we were
threatened with a $500 fine for even
asking about entering although later the
NSA gave us some
footage these students at a nearby local
University were threatened with arrest
for photographing an NSA building on
their campus where whistleblower Ed
Snowden once worked
piur can't pictures not at all NSA used
to stand for never say anything this has
changed because the surveillance state
is in the news every day Americans know
it exists but few really understand what
it does and how to find out also don't
bother visiting the NSA website I'm
often asked the question what's more
important civil liberties or national
security
it's a false question it's a false
choice at the end of the day we must do
both you will only find out what they
want you to know that they are here to
defend and protect you they claim to be
accountable in legal and moral terms we
have to find the way to ensure that we
support the entirety of the Constitution
that was the intention of the framers of
the Constitution that's what we do on a
daily basis at the National Security
Agency how true is that we will
investigate the claims and the realities
in this episode of America's
surveillance
[Music]
[Applause]
State what does the NSA do it's a simple
question but because it's a Top Secret
Agency a clear understanding has been
hard to grasp the agency is not required
to release even
nonclassified information on November
6th 1998 NSA for the first time
Declassified this organization chart of
its operations directorate you will note
some of this document is blacked out it
also only shows part of nsa's mission
including Military Support intelligence
oversight and policy Global issues and
Military production and here what they
call collection operations that's
another word for electronic
eavesdropping it has become well known
but also controversial because of all
the data that is being collected and
stored you have this incredible uh
advances in in technology that enable
much more collection than than ever was
possible and a an increase of secrecy
around the program so it's very unclear
still not just what the government is
doing but what legal authorities it
thinks allows it to do what it's doing
Mike German a veteran undercover FBI
agent knows surveillance techniques
because he's used them it's an enormous
problem for the government to know more
about the people than the people know
about what the government's doing and
what we've seen since the terrorist
attacks of 9/11 is that a lot of the
legal restraints that that kept the
government in check after a previous era
of abuse
uh were relaxed or removed completely in
many cases the NSA was created secretly
60 years ago not by Congress but by the
president as a tool of the Cold War but
it always got less attention than the
Spooks spies and assassins who built the
cia's Mystique as the invulnerable and
omnipotent overthrower of governments
and silencer of America's
enemies CIA scandals including a
recently leaked document detailing is
role in torture and abuse became well
known even as the nsa's better funded
operations were downplayed because they
were considered the province of super
nerds boys with toys Like Satellites
cables and
supercomputers NSA hires more
mathematicians than any other Federal
agency Reay McGovern was in the CIA and
Rose to become a briefer of presidents
he worked for seven presidents and nine
directors of Central Intelligence he
says he joined because he believed in
the mission the ethos of intelligence
work that attracted me was uh symbolized
by the scriptural quote on the fo of the
cia's new building it was new 1963 when
I came on under John Kennedy and it said
You shall know the truth and the truth
shall set you free okay and I said
looked at that and I remembered the the
constant victim of my Irish grandmother
be truthful and honest and then you
won't give a damn what anyone says about
you okay and so I looked there I say
grandma if that's true you know no pun
intended it's going to be a good place
to work eventually like many
professionals he became disillusioned
retiring early as a member of the
intelligence Community he came to know
the nsa's work well NSA did play a role
we learned things about the Soviet Union
we never would have known known before
uh it was done with uh judiciousness and
above all it was done with respect to
what they call the first commandment out
there at Fort me NSA Thou shalt not
collect information EES drop on
Americans without a Court warrant that
was the rule that was the first
commandment when Cheney came in he said
they called The General Hayden who was
head of NSA at the time he said General
Hayden I know about that first
commandment N I say I know about that
forget about it for get about it and
that was before 911 so the decision for
the NSA to begin collecting information
on everyone in everything started with
an order from above oh sure you it was
Dick Cheney and and and George Bush the
other thing of course that needs to be
said is that the technology allowed that
for the first time and so when you had
the sort of the the rubric here collect
everything which clearly is their motto
now collect everything and then they say
well you know what people say what about
the the problem with the Hast stack
finding an needle in a Hast stack all
the answer to that they say is you got
to make sure you had the whole Hast
stack this NSA document leaked by Ed
Snowden describes their collection
program this way collect it all sniff it
all know it all process it all exploit
it all NSA whistleblower Russ Ty says
the agency is still downplaying its
collect process to make it sound
harmless they're lying about what they
have and their capabilities and what
they're doing they're archiving
everything their their their their idea
is we'll archive everything we're going
we're going to take everything and then
they say oh well we we don't collect
well then they're lying of course but
their definition of collect is to have
some human analyst look at at this email
or or listen to this phone call or
whatever well of course that's nonsense
they've collected it and they have it
for Lord you know for in an indefinite
period of time but they're not going to
call it collected until someone looks at
it and of course there's no way we have
enough humans on this planet to listen
to every you know communication that
happens they are also not talking about
how collecting everything makes it
harder to produce relevant
intelligence is there a danger of of you
know valuable information getting lost
because so much is collected I mean this
is what they said after 9/11 you know
they had information about these
hijackers but nothing was dumb because
there was so much information they
couldn't figure out who to go after and
and the Boston bombers and the underwear
bombers and the shoe bombers all these
all these things you know because
they've P you know they're say they you
got to look for a needle in the hay
stack well you know part of my job in
that world was to make sure to First
limit the size of the hay stack that way
you don't have as much hay to go through
before to look for the needle and what
they're doing is just dumping on more
hay they're they're they're you don't
have a hay stack anymore you have a
mountain of hay to go through State
surveillance today is now cheap it's
undetectable it's pervasive and it's
available at the click of a mouse as a
result entire populations rather than
individuals now live under constant
surveillance whistleblower Ed Snowden
went through that hay and saw a lot of
disturbing images Wars and abuses as a
network administrator he had access to
all the databases and soon realized that
he had the power to spy on anyone in a
video prepared for a televised debate he
explained despite policy I as an NSA
analist sitting at my desk had the
technical authority to wiretap anyone
from a federal judge to the president of
the United States without getting out of
my chair as long as I had a private
email address and that's not a
boast in fact some of these cases have
already happened in 2009 the New York
Times reported that an NSA analyst used
our state surveillance infrastructure to
improperly access Bill Clinton's
email and other NSA workers have used
State surveillance to spy on their
lovers ex-girlfriends and other
individuals who are obviously not
suspected of any crime at all or any
kind of
wrongdoing it's important to note that
none of those individuals were ever
charged with crimes and we have to ask
ourselves why is that journalist Glenn
Greenwald has now released some of
snowden's documents in his new book that
confronts the NSA head on the same
rhetoric is constantly invoked which is
if you shine a light on what we in
political power are doing in a way that
we haven't authorize you to do you're
going to have blood on your hands I mean
there's an obvious irony to being
accused by a US general who served in
Iraq of all places of having blood on
your hands or resulting causing the
death of innocent people nobody could
ever surpass Keith Alexander and his
fellow Generals in their ability to do
that what we've seen is a uh expansion
of what we call secret law where they're
either working under authorities that
the American public doesn't know about
or even worse there is a law in the
books but they're interpreting in a way
that the an objective reading of that
law wouldn't ordinarily allow the NSA in
the hot seat documents leaked by Edwards
Snowden showed that the NSA may have
been spying on Chancellor Angela Merkel
an old mobile phone number she used is
listed in those documents Germany not
happy soon thanks to the Snowden
disclosures and media investigations we
found out that the NSA was collecting
Intel on 122 foreign leaders even us
allies like the chancellor of Germany
and the president of Brazil 35 leaders
had their calls monitored for Germany it
is is unacceptable that the mobile phone
of our federal Chancellor may have been
subject to surveillance activities by
our American partners for us spying on
close friends and partners is totally
unacceptable the NSA speaks of its work
in neutral and non-threatening language
using terms like collection telephony
metadata what does that mean we asked
former FBI undercover agent Mike German
I mean you would normally think in the
terms of the fourth amendment that any
time the government is collecting
information about you Gathering it
putting it in a in a government database
that that would be collection but often
the way the uh authorities that govern
government surveillance uh are
interpreted sometimes acquisition the
acquisition of information versus the
collection of information are two
different things and they're only
considering it collected once a human
being has actually put eyes on it and
processed the
information in May 2014 former NSA
director Michael Hayden shocked a
Washington audience when he said that
the NSA uses metadata to kill people a
reference to NSA providing intelligence
to military units using drones to
assassinate people the Pentagon and the
White House consider enemies Hayden
quickly backtracked saying we do that in
the US correct okay we kill people based
on
metadata but that's not what we do with
this metad
Adam
thankfully wow I was working up a sweat
there for a
second Hayden now working with a former
Homeland Security Chief was also
embarrassed in October 2013 when he was
overheard by a fellow train passenger
who began twe ing the content of his
confidential phone
conversation using a secret fisa Court
to do its bidding the NSA pressed the
government to order phone companies like
Verizon AT&T Sprint and Nextel to turn
over a massive number of Records later
we learned about a program called prism
here's the secret NSA document that
shows what it does to collect internet
data virtually every everything we do
and say online from all the big
companies well they're collecting
everything they can collect and that is
everything they've been doing that
without any adult supervision the White
House the the the Committees in Congress
who are supposed to be exercising
oversight right they're the Overlook
committees not the oversight committees
and they're they're complicit in that
not only that but you have these 15 Fox
judges from the fisa court the foreign
intelligence surveillance act Court foe
means phony right yeah fux yeah yeah and
uh so what you have Danny and this is
important for the first time in my my
life you have the executive you have
important people in the legislative
branch the heads of the intelligence
committees and you have 15 judges on the
fisa court all sort of
Imes all complicit in this gross
violation of the Fourth Amendment and
you start out asking about NSA what it
stands for now it stands for No Such
Amendment no such Amendment just to
summarize what is NSA NSA is the largest
most costly and most technologically
sophisticated spy organization the world
has ever known it filters millions of
phone calls and emails an hour it has
computers programmed to watch for
hundreds of thousands of names its
computers cost tens of millions and
carry strange names like black widow
they run at special speeds most of us
have never heard of hundreds of Tera
flops that can lead to hundreds of
trillions of operations per second NSA
headquarters is four times bigger than
the US capital I love the place I went
into the military and the Air Force when
Ronald Reagan was President um I was I
was Full Throttle we were fighting the
Cold War against the evil Soviet Union
and um and I was a full believer I mean
I was gung-ho and and you know I'd be
the guy that would get in early and stay
late and you know I I wanted to to do my
job and I love the place Russ Ty
typified the NSA mentality a space
engineer he believed in their
clandestine Mission and was totally
dedicated he worked in super secret
so-called black World programs until he
discovered that the satellites were not
just spying on America's enemies in one
of these programs I found out that we
were using our we were using satellite
technology to uh spy on American
citizens spy on American citizens yes
not supposed to do that right no in in
NSA every six month months you go
through a program where they drill it
into your head we call it usid 18 that
you will not spy on Americans and for
one incident of spying on Americans you
can go to jail for five years for one
incident and they drill that into your
head and and we're and we all believe
that we will never do this to our fellow
citizens William Benny was a 40-year
veteran of NSA who also went off the
reservation because he saw the agency
straying from its job he was interviewed
by democracy Now that the the Congress
and the administration have been have
been fed by the by the intelligence
Community what I call
technobabble in other words they're
being Bamboozled into thinking a certain
way that they have to do this in order
to get terrorists and that's simply
false speaking of terrorists the most
dramatic NSA story we heard came from
Thomas Drake who became an executive at
NSA on the day of a terrorist attack
September 11th 2001
almost 3,000 people were
murdered the workforce knew that this
was not just a passing crisis the
workforce knew that we had utterly
failed the nation we we under the
Constitution the pre of the Constitution
government has two primary
responsibilities one is to provide for
the common defense the other is provide
for the general
welfare here we utterly fail we had not
kept people out of Harm's Way we had not
protected the nation there was a feeling
of guilt there because the NSA had
information on some of the men who
skyjacked those planes that were flown
into buildings but they did not share it
with other
agencies Thomas Drake became an
eyewitness to how the agency changed so
I became eyewitness to NSA unchaining
itself with the approval and the Mandate
of the White House on chaining itself
from the Fourth Amendment
literally and entering into a mass uh
surveillance
regime the likes that history has never
seen
before as he became critical of the
agency's failures he became a
whistleblower and faced years in prison
for going public with NSA failures
unlike Edward Snowden he did not leak
masses of documents that was one of the
fundamental rules whether it was oral
communication whether it was written
electronic or later on even in hard copy
it was all unclassified period what's
not appreciated is that Snowden has been
as careful in assembling information as
he has been in disseminating information
if I had just wanted to harm the US you
know
that you could shut down the the
surveillance system in an
afternoon um but that's not my intention
and I I think for anyone um making that
argument they need to think if they were
in my position
uh and you know you live a privileged
life you you're living in Hawaii in
paradise and making a ton of money what
would it take to make you leave
everything behind thanks to what we've
learned from snowden's disclosures it
seems like all of us have been reduced
to the data we convey when you engage in
electronic transaction whether it's with
your cell phone with a regular
traditional uh landline phone uh with
your credit card card uh with your
computer uh the transaction itself the
content of the communications is called
content you know if you buy something at
the store with your credit card what you
bought is is considered content um but
there are all sorts of electronic Trails
left like crumbs uh that often have a
tremendous amount of very detailed
information about you particularly when
it's gathered in Mass uh for for example
who you called when you called them how
long you were on on the call with them
where you made the call from that type
of
data collected in Mass can reveal an
awful lot of information about you in
May 2014 Washington finally took legal
action against cyber spying by China not
the United States even as some of the
Snowden documents revealed that economic
Espionage is also in nsa's portfolio the
Chinese and US critics laughed at what
they called
hypocrisy the United States deliberately
made up facts using the excuse of So-Cal
stealing of Secrets online to indict
five Chinese military officials this has
seriously violated the basic principles
of international relations and damaged
Chinese us cooperation and mutual trust
Americans think it's okay if we spy on
foreigners but it's not okay if we spy
on Americans as if you know the rest of
the world has no right to privacy at all
we are more worried about Al-Qaeda than
I I think any nation state as a a threat
to American lives uh but nonetheless we
I think we have to reign in an agency
that has the ability to spy on any
innocent citizen with impunity of any
country in the world I mean when the
world becomes the nsaa's panopticon even
with a you know a figgly for privacy
around
Americans uh that to me does seem
unacceptable and and it turns the whole
world against this coming up next the
NSA and the Press how spying and
intimidation has led America's
mainstream media to push back and
publish leaks and disclosures that would
have once been Unthinkable the Press
versus the
NSA the New York Times has considered
America's most powerful newspaper its
offices near Manhattan's Times Square
projects that power for a media
institution that often sets the
political agenda and tells us what's
important and yet today there is also
Fear and Loathing inside New York Times
newsrooms where journalists increasingly
feel threatened even intimidated by an
Administration that has prosecuted more
whistleblowers eight in all than any
other in American history in March 2014
the times Conference Center hosted a
forum to address the state of press
Freedom packed it was like a media
Summit of major players there to resist
the growing power of the surveillance
State distributed at the event was this
2014 report on attacks on the press the
committee to protect journalists charges
that the NSA puts journalists under a
cloud of
Suspicion
[Music]
we're at the New York Times Center uh in
Manhattan for a conference on sources
and secrets some of the top journalists
in America are here to debate and
discuss the growth of the the
surveillance state in America
journalists feel threatened politicians
now feel threatened this seems to be an
issue that's gone from the back pages to
the front page Ralph englman works with
the pulk awards sponsoring a respected
awards ceremony in an industry that is
far more competitive than collaborative
confidentiality of sources is Central to
uh the work of of journalists
investigative journalists in particular
and in addition the use of the Espionage
Act what we've learned from the the
Snowden Revelations about the NSA uh how
can you guarantee
confidentiality Engelman sees this event
not just as a get together for reporters
but one with an important political
Mission I think there is something that
has not been said directly that needs to
be said and that is that the sort of
political context for this whole crisis
in terms of of of Journalism and
surveillance and the the use of the
Espionage Act of 1917 if you go back to
the original Act of 1917 it was passed
in large measure to suppress anti-war
sentiment sentiment against us entry
into the War uh first world war it's not
simply a question of journalistic
practice but it's also a question of
American foreign policy the ability of
journalists and the public to follow
what's going on an issue today is the
case of James ryzen a Times Reporter who
exposed warrantless wiretapping you know
since after we
had reported on the story and nailed it
down uh
we went to the government for comment
for comment in fact I went to Michael
Hayden who was then the director of the
NSA and got him on the phone and
uh told him what we were writing and and
uh before he realized what he was doing
he had given me an on the record
comment and then as soon very quickly
after that he and the Bush
Administration started putting pressure
on my
editors uh demanding that we not run the
story former veteran CIA analyst Ray
McGovern says that at first there was an
effort to suppress ryzen's story James
ryzen had this story in the summer of
2004 it was that Dick Cheney and George
Bush had told General Hayden to collect
everything and forget about this first
amendment at NSA about not collecting on
Americans while the court or just
collect everything okay now uh that was
discovered in the summer of 2004 but the
New York Times superiors of James ryzen
went to the White House and
said and and the election is coming up
and so George Bush said don't that's
National Security National Security
terrorism term Fear National Security do
not publish that story The Times
initially sat on the report but then
ryzen told his boss publisher author
solsberg that this story will be told in
his new book The Times publisher then
told the White House the newspaper would
be going ahead and so salsberg calls the
White House and says I'm sorry we're
going to have to publish on that now
Bush orders him into the oval officers
to tell him no you can't do that he
orders the publisher of the New York
Times into the White House right and the
publisher of the New York Times and the
Washington bureau chief dutifully show
up there and Bush says you can't do that
okay now this is the 5th of December
2005 you can't do that okay and they
said well you know hey we held off for
15 months for God say you know you got
to understand so what happened here is
that uh the New York Times caved and
Michael Hayden uh was uh was asked to
explain all this in January of 2006 so
one month after ryon's Revelations he
gets up before the national Press Club
and he's asked by Jonathan Landy it's on
it's right on the it's on YouTube uh
General Hayden um why is it that you
have sort of played fast and loose with
the Fourth Amendment Fourth Amendment
actually uh protects all of us against
unreasonable search and seizure that's
what says the measure is probable cause
I believe the amendment says
unreasonable search and seizure but does
it not say
Pro but the NSA director was wrong
probable cause is in the Fourth
Amendment but ryzen is still being
ordered by the courts to reveal his
source and he's resisting leading to an
ongoing clash and a possible jail ter
they trying to do they're trying to kind
of create a a path for accepted
reporting and that if you as a
reporter go outside those parameters
that you'll be punished and that the
sources that you will that you are uh
trying to deal with will be prosecuted
media oldtimers like retired times
editor Seymour topping sees a larger
context too we're living in a period of
uh of
terrorism uh of uh of danger uh uh on
questions affecting National
Security uh and therefore the the whole
question uh of the role of the press uh
becomes and its relationship with the
government becomes more and more
important it's important that the public
become more and more aware of the
problems confronting the Press
journalists in the building like Bill
kavich and other former times bureau
chief were also very conscious of what
happened to another building in New York
the World Trade Center creating the
pretext for the rise of massive
government spying when the Trade Center
went down all bets were off who was
going to challenge the government nobody
was not we didn't do it the Press didn't
do it the government had the opportunity
and George W bush opened all the doors
so fast forward to the present day we
have situations where newspapers like
the one you you work for here are
actually willing to work with
whistleblowers and and bring out
information that maybe in the past they
wouldn't have done as as quickly
although we do have the Pentagon papers
as and I helped work on the Pentagon
papers we were ready to do it the times
was ready to do it at any time if they
could confirm the information you know
we got the Pentagon papers dumped but we
rented two floors of a hotel over here
for a month and vetted that data
ourselves so we did our own reporting Mr
Erman are you telling me that the break
in to Dr fielding's office was to
satisfy by the president of the United
States the president wanted very much to
make sure that a thing like this could
not happen
again how one
learned whether Ellsberg acted alone as
a disgruntled employee of a think tank
whether he acted as a member of an
international spiring delivering secrets
to a foreign Embassy or just what his
role was where he fed had to be
determined in the opinion of the
investigators by every available means
did you have a sense of mission which is
unusual in journalism a sense of you
know you're actually uncovering
something of value and importance to the
American people that's the only reason
to be a journalist I mean democracy you
know as well as I do democracy only
survives on on a population that has the
kind of information that allows them to
make a decision to help make a democracy
work and if the Press doesn't do it who
will this is not just an American
problem journalists in other countries
are being spied on too by the NSA and
their own intelligence agencies says Tim
mcel if you look at uh journalists in
other countries they risk a great deal
more than we risk we we may be you know
prosecuted or we may it end up with um
adverse publicity or things like that
but we rarely feel that our lives are
threatened that our livelihoods are
threatened that our amili uh the
journalists in many other countries are
not only more aggressive uh they're more
courageous this sources and secrets
conference included exchanges with
representatives of the intelligence
Community who argued that whistleblowers
like Edward Snowden should be in prison
it is my personal opinion Jim ryzen
called me out on this that people who
leak classified information commit
crimes and if we can catch them which is
not always easy we ought to prosecute
them and they ought to go to jail here's
Robert ly who is General Counsel for the
Director of National Intelligence there
there are many many things the
government believes need to be kept
secret secret in the National interest
and there's a full recognition of the
fact that the Press is almost invariably
going to balance that interest different
than the government does and so there's
going to be necessarily an adversarial
relationship and the question is what
kind of processes can we set up um to
ensure that that adversarial
relationship uh is a productive one
rather than a destructive one the panels
also included journalists who have been
disseminating and Publishing Secrets
leaked by Snowden like the Washington
posts Barton Gilman and independents
like Glenn Greenwald and Laura pus
Edward Snowden is a rockar to some to
others of course he is a traitor and
here
today via Skype uh we have the three
journalists who were entrusted uh by
Snowden chosen by Snowden to be the
recipients of top secret NSA
archives do you feel it's essential do
you systematically run by the government
ask for government response on the
stories you've done on the Snowden
Revelations or um other stories about
the NSA we've had the legal framework
since I don't know the alien ins
Sedition Acts uh and the Espionage Act
of 97 years ago uh with which a
government could prosecute journalists
for talking about secrets and it has
been a legal culture a political culture
uh that's created the barriers today
Greenwald and pitus have worked directly
with leading newspapers to report
Secrets buried in these documents he did
not think that he should be in the
position to decide which documents ought
to be published and which ones ought to
be suppressed he came to wellestablished
and well-regarded newspap papers and
asked the journalist in those
institutions with whom he was working to
make those judgments about what is in
the public interest to publish and what
is not and specifically at least to me
said a lot of what I'm giving you is for
background for context for understanding
um but I don't think all of this should
be published if I just wanted all of
this published I wouldn't need you guys
I could have just uploaded it to the
internet myself the thing that has I
think been um positive in terms of
snowden's disclosures is it's a
reawakened an adversarial um press and
and that people have been shocked that
these things these decisions about
surveillance have been made completely
in secret completely without public
debate and um and and that there does
seem to be um some kind of an Awakening
but I I don't I wouldn't call it a shift
of the
pendulum and now an initially skeptical
American Media has showered them with
top prizes Greenwald poetress and Gilman
won the admired pulk Awards the next
question would the media honor Edward
snowden's contribution as a
whistleblower in the end they didn't but
newspapers that carried his leaks did
win the even more prestigious pullit
surprise these reports were not always
picked up or praised because
establishment journalism does not trust
Crusaders like Greenwald and pess says
Rory o Conor of Stonybrook University
because they're too independent and
because even as you heard the editors of
the top Publications here the New York
Times The Washington Post and New Yorker
and so on all of them said on the panels
today in fact that they have not been
aggressive enough that they have
collaborated perhaps too much with the
government in the past this these are
the people who won the major media
organizations being self-critical and
saying no we don't need to have more
humility which is what was suggested by
Mr lit the representative of the uh NSA
and the and the CIA he said that the
Press needed more humility I was pleased
at least that the leaders of the
mainstream organization struck back
against that and said no we don't need
more humility we need more aggressive
reporting and I agree with that before
the big prize was given Publications
like the magazine Politico framed the
challenge facing the powers who run
establishment
journalism wrote media critic Dylan
buers honoring the NSA reporting would
inevitably be perceived as a political
act with the Pulitzer committee invoking
its prestige on behalf of one side in a
bitter National argument yet to pass on
the NSA story would be to risk giving
the appearance of timidity the major
media resolved the debate this way they
recognized the Snowden disclosures
without recognizing him or the people
closest to him Snowden was
magnanimous saying today's decision is a
Vindication for everyone who believes
that the public has a role in government
we owe it to the efforts of Brave
reporters and their colleagues who keep
working in the face of extraordinary
intimidation Ben Weisner snowden's
lawyer from the American civil liberties
Union also praised the Press uh I do
think that the last year in particular
has been an extraordinary year for
journalists uh particularly American
journalists that that they have been you
know courageous um in standing up in the
face of government claims of National
Security um that they have not ignored
those government claims they have
redacted stories where appropriate but
in general you know they understood that
the balance had tipped far too much
towards difference has the big media now
recognize the value of whistleblowers in
the Press other media Outlets say they
have to be more aggressive in their own
reporting and not just rely on documents
that are leaked Jonathan land is an
investigator ative reporter for the
Washington Bureau of mcache newspapers I
don't email sources um uh we just broke
the St the story on uh the big fight
between the CIA and the Senate
intelligence committee most of the
groundbreaking work on that was done by
a 22-year-old freelance paid freelancer
who did nothing but doorstep uh uh
committees on on the hill uh go to
people's homes got me doing that again
uh going out uh at night to visit people
um and and and that's how we were able
to do that without and without sort of
like sitting in the office and taking
phone calls the issues at this
conference on the rights of the press
also deal with another right the right
of the public to be informed about what
governments do in their name that's the
focus of Amy Goodman's
concern Goodman is an anchor of a
popular independent daily newscast
called democracy now in information is
the oxygen of a democracy it's not just
about uh participating in Democratic
processes it's about being
informed that's what makes democracy
meaningful and when we don't have that
information when a very powerful entity
the government has the information and
the people don't that is not a very
healthy sign it does not bode well for
democracy Goodman is a strong believer
in the Freedom of Information Act that
guarantees access to government
information when the ACT is respected
she cites one current example of the
government insisting on keeping secret
something that happened 60 years ago the
issue is the US role if any in the
arrest of South Africa's late leader
Nelson Mandela in
1962 Ryan Shapiro an MIT graduate
student is now suing for the information
after the government turned down his
request Ryan Shapiro the graduate
student at MIT has sued for more
information under the Freedom of
Information Act than anyone in US
history and one of the issues he cares
deeply about is what happened to Nelson
Mandela how was it that he was picked up
in the early 60s was it just the South
African government or it was was Nelson
Mandela targeted by the CIA and
intelligence given over to the South
African apartate regime um and why is it
that something that took place more than
half a century ago we not we can't learn
about today um that is a very serious
question that doesn't have to do with
National Security that has to do with
embarrassment and that is not acceptable
in the end this is a fight to keep the
public informed you don't just achieve
democracy people have to fight for it
every single day have to be ever
Vigilant so now that the information is
out there and we don't even have all of
the information people have to decide
what they want to do how much power they
want to imbue in the government so what
will come from calls to action like Amy
Goodman's and mainstream media
conferences the crying the problem you
know I think nothing will come out of
events like this honestly to to answer
your question you know the final panel
was uh was entitled where do we go from
here but actually it was very very
little of anyone addressing where we go
from here we're at a state here in the
United States right now where the Press
is under attack by the Obama
Administration a greater attack than any
previous administration in fact then all
previous administrations roll together
and so what the question is where does
the media Go From Here fac with this
attack face with the threat of a further
imprisonment on the part of uh you know
times reporters like Jim ryzen you know
the mainstream media themselves are
under attack and I think that what one
thing I'm hoping you're going to see is
a a greater Unity among the media NSA
whistleblowers like Russ Ty say that the
NSA at first labeled him paranoid to
discredit him with the Press paranoid is
right they use Paranoid and they did it
on purpose I think because they realized
that if I ever did go to the Press
that's exactly what they would say to
the Press because remember back then
there there aren't any I'm I'm the
original NSA you know uh whistleblower
when this with this sort of thing this
is you know 2004 2005 Ty frame so you
know when I finally did come out that's
exactly what they did they said you're
you're talking to crazy guy do you want
your source to be the crazy guy you know
you know so in other words even though
you had information and speculation that
was informed they basically attempted to
discredit you well of course yes but now
whistleblowers are fighting back by
working together and getting society and
the media to recognize their
contribution another recent award named
after Ron Rau a soldier who exposed the
migi massacre in Vietnam in which US
soldiers slaughtered Villages and
children saluted Ed Snowden and the
reporters bringing his documents to the
public I'm very happy to be here very
honored to be here to uh make this
introduction uh to two Extraordinary
People Laura pitris and Edward Snowden
author James Bamford the first to expose
NSA activities introduced the winners a
live message by Ed Snowden now living in
Exile in Russia was heard do you think
it's
right that the NSA is collecting more
information about Americans in America
than it is about Russians in Russia
because that's what our systems do we
watch our own own people more closely
than we watch any other population in
the world despite the
protections they are policy based the
Technical Systems ingest and collect
everyone in this room's uh communication
when you pick up the phone when you make
a call when you make a purchase when you
buy a book all of that is collected and
I could see it at my desk crossing my
screen former CIA analyst greay mg
govern says that journalists are not the
only ones who fear the power of the NSA
then you ask about the journalists
you're asking about Well everybody's
afraid I mean it's not just the
journalists it's people like Barack
Obama it's people like Diane Feinstein
think about what the NSA has on Diane
Feinstein and her husband who has made
billions from defense and post office
and all kind of nice cozy contracts okay
so everybody's afraid not just
journalists let me just understand this
you're saying that President Obama in
your opinion informed opinion has
reasons to fear the power of the NSA has
to be careful in terms of the dance he's
done about yes he'll reform it but not
too much well Danny when you're
collecting everything on everybody you
know who who Among Us is is as pure as
Caesar's wife you know everybody's got
something to hide that's you know that's
the idsy of these people say I got
nothing to hide you know well you know
everyone things they want to
hide coming up next in our surveillance
series the interface between the spy
agencies and the technology companies
can their cooperation be considered
complicity in spying do they violate the
trust of customers
[Music]
next